This is the most interesting fighting in the last five years.
With the European elections around the corner,
we wanted to know who were the greenest politicians in Europe.
But how did we do this? Well,
we had to collect the data from all the political parties in Europe.
Second, we created a scoring system
and we assigned them a grade based on how they acted on three topics
nature, climate, pollution.
Third, we created this web page where we put all the info for everyone
to find out how greens the different parties are.
So what are the results? In the EU Parliament,
the group that ranked the highest was the greens,
followed by the left and the Socialists.
In the middle we find renew.
And the groups with their lowest score
where the European People's Party,
the conservative and the far right.
So now you know which are the greenest parties in Europe.